[Music]
straight ahead online crime daily
my fun is missing the disappearance of
gabby potito shines a light on missing
persons of color we retrace the last
known steps of daniel robinson and our
pre-trial hearing gets heated you posted
something on your personal facebook
account about the case sir and you
acknowledge that you did it i should not
have done it correct one half of the
doomsday duel asked that his trial be
moved plus sentencing dave for a serial
killer after a coven 19 delay it is a
total of 160 years with 145 years of
corollary khalil wheeler weaver's fate
sealed and later inside the
interrogation
defendant mark gooch asked point blank
his involvement in the meta knight
murder law on crime daily covering court
cases from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin the widespread coverage of gali
patil's disappearance has prompted
questions about why other cases of
missing people don't get the same level
of attention bringing light to other
missing persons law and crimes angela
levy is here with one case out of
arizona in which the missing man's
father is pleading for help
brian daniel robinson is a geologist
who's been missing from buckeye arizona
since june 23 and his father has been
looking for him ever since
daniel robinson's disappearance is a
mystery his father would like to solve
my son daniel robinson is a
geologist he works for a matrix new
world
also known as matrix southwest
groundwater on june 23 david robinson
said his son met a man from another
company at a job site according to a
buckeye police report the man said
daniel was saying things that didn't
make sense and drove away a rancher
found daniel's jeep 26 days later on
july 19th in a ravine
i was told by the buckeye police
department when they came to the scene
they
found my son's cell phone inside his
vehicle
the keys to his vehicle
also a work computer robinson says
daniel's wallet was inside his pants
pocket in his clothing which you can see
on the ground near the suv
the buckeye police department in arizona
says it has searched 70 square miles for
daniel robinson since june late last
month officers posted photos on facebook
showing a well they searched with no
sign of daniel david robinson is
skeptical about the search efforts
they decided to do a search because of
the pressure that's been put on by the
media a buckeye police spokesperson
released a statement from the police
chief that says we are committed to
finding daniel robinson our
investigators are working tirelessly to
find answers and bring closure to
daniel's loved ones a spokesperson
telling me there is no evidence of foul
play
hello hello and good morning the
attention gabby potito's case received
prompted her parents to ask the media to
focus on other cases involving missing
people former new york city police
detective kirk burkhalter
if there's any
possible
positive outcome that can come from all
this tragedy it would be that law
enforcement but take a look at how they
investigate missing persons cases
involving adults young adults meanwhile
david robinson hopes the attention on
daniel's case will bring him home
daniel's loved by his family he loves
all his friends
he have a way of bringing people
together
daniel's father has relocated from south
carolina to arizona to search for him he
also has a private investigator working
on the case and it's important to to
mention that while that vehicle was
crashed there wasn't any blood found in
the vehicle that would suggest somebody
had been injured brian
thanks angenet an update on a story we
brought you earlier this week officials
in florida confirm the remains found
over the weekend are that of missing 19
year old mia marcano
like robinson marcano's case received
national attention after people noted
the lack of reporting from missing
persons of color in the media marcona
was last seen on september 24th at the
apartment complex in orlando where she
lived and worked the prime suspect
armando emanuel cabollero was found dead
by apparent suicide three days after
marcano went missing caballero was a
maintenance worker who lived in
marcano's building and had reportedly
shown romantic interest in her she
refused him several times according to
cell phone records caballero was in
maricano's apartment the night of her
disappearance right now the cause of her
death is still unknown
meanwhile new information comes to light
as the manhunt for fugitive brian
laundry stretches into another day after
weeks of misinformation laundry's family
now says the 23 year old left his
florida family home a day earlier than
was originally reported that means brian
laundry has been missing since monday
september 13th just two days after gabby
potido was reported missing longie's
family say he left their home without a
cell phone or wallet it's been more than
three weeks without any confirmed
sightings of him still dozens of tips
have reached north carolina law
enforcement as hikers report seeing
laundry along the appalachian trail this
week petito's family appeared on dr phil
calling for brian laundry to turn
himself in
we want to know the truth
because if you truly loved her
you should turn yourself in
you're only making it worse
for us
and for himself and for his family
let us have some closure
let us come to an end to this
tragic period
and just move on and be able to remember
gabby for all the
wonderful memories we had with her
joining us today is criminal defense
attorney mike coreyvonix and terry
austin mike you helped build
investigations as a former prosecutor
and dismantle them on cross as a defense
attorney how's the search of brian
laundry going in your eyes
well it appears this is a very difficult
search it's very unusual because we're
so used to seeing people be caught in
cities and things of that nature where
you really can't walk without a video
camera tracking you this is different
he's out in the wilderness and
i i think it's going as best they can
but i i really have a feeling that that
there may be some issues in this case of
whether or not he's still alive because
of what we just heard in the previous
other missing person who the suspect
they were looking for committed suicide
it appeared yeah it seems to be quite
some time but the family of laundry has
said he does have some minor survival of
skills we'll see how that plays out
terry with the nation's attention on the
issue of missing persons what do you
think can be done to have less of these
stories
brian we need to pay attention and we
all need to pay attention to these
missing persons stories it's really
horrible and tragic but they need to be
investigated and the media needs to pay
more attention to all of these stories
the authorities obviously need to
investigate each case seriously because
only when we solve these cases will we
be able to determine what the causation
is and what the circumstances were and
if we can do that then we can avoid some
of these cases the fbi statistics say
that women and people of color are
affected more with these missing cases
because they are less investigated and
it turns out that they classify them as
runaways so we need to fix that
the hope is that by bringing attention
to all of these missing persons it
creates more eyes and ears on the ground
to help find these people and those
accused and jeanette back to daniel
robinson there was some information
police have about him being interested
in a woman before he went missing right
right that's right brian in the couple
of weeks before he went missing he had
met a woman named caitlin and it appears
he became very fond of her there's a
police report that the buckeye police
department released when i requested it
it's 54 pages long so far and it details
that daniel was interested in this woman
but she apparently told police she was
not interested in him and the last time
they spoke was the day the day before he
disappeared all right interesting update
thank you very much angina as well as
mike and terry still ahead on law and
crime daily years after a triple murder
conviction serial killer khalil wheeler
weaver is finally sentenced but first
will the half of the doomsday cult duo
have a change in their trial venue more
on what's in store for chad dabo after
this
[Music]
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live law
one crime network with youtube tv for
all of your daily live trial coverage
legal news expert analysis and original
true crime programs subscribe to youtube
tv today and then locate law and crime
in the channel guide and for only 1.99 a
month you can add the network to your
bundle watch lawn crime every day with
youtube tv we put you in the jury box
[Music]
welcome back a trial location is still
up in the air for half of the so-called
doomsday duo chad dabo appeared in court
on tuesday where his defense attorneys
and the prosecution got heated day
bell's attorneys argue a fair and
impartial jury cannot be found in
fremont county idaho that's where daebel
and his wife laurie valo davil were last
arrested last year the pair faced
multiple charges including conspiracy to
commit murder and first-degree murder in
september 2019 valo's children tyler
ryan and j.j valo went missing their
bodies were found in june 2020 on
daybell's property debalan vallo also
shared apocalyptic end-of-time beliefs
making way for their nickname as the
doomsday duo in tuesday's hearing dabo's
attorney pointed out the intense media
coverage brought upon the rural
community after dabo's arrest and
pointed a finger at the fremont county
sheriff saying he showed bias in the
case
fremont county is a relatively rural
county would you agree with that
that's correct and you would agree with
me that there's been a significant in
fact a great amount of uh
um
a press coverage as it relates to this
case correct
there has been
and you would agree with me that the
press coverage in fremont county alone
has been saturated with uh a variety of
photos videos stories from east idaho
news and others correct
numerous outlets
right and you would agree in this small
rural community
with that amount of significant press
coverage
and a sheriff who's the county sheriff
in that
you don't think that you posting things
about the valo day bell case has an
impact on some of the citizens of
fremont county sheriff
i don't know what impact would be post
what i do not know what impact that
would have
okay
but you would agree there'd be an impact
right
there could be
okay and you would agree that it was
probably a bad choice to post things
about chad dabal and lori valo on your
facebook account you'd agree with that
right
i do agree with that
okay
let's bring back criminal defense
attorney mike corombonics and terry
austin terry people from hawaii to maine
have been following this couple's case
partly because they traveled all over
the country where does the defense think
they'll get an impartial jury
that is a great question brian it
doesn't matter if they're in fremont or
madison or
you know wherever it's not going to be a
trial by a jury that has not heard about
this case everyone has heard about this
case partially because they traveled a
lot but also because it involved
children who obviously were found dead
in the backyard for chad daybell and i
think the real issue here is not whether
they find a jury who hasn't heard about
this case but whether they find jurors
who are going to be impartial there is a
constitutional right to be tried and
have it be impartial so it's a real
serious issue and it's an issue that
will be talked about on appeal i
guarantee it absolutely mike how do you
think the judge will rule on this issue
and what does that mean for lori
valodebel's case
well i i think the judge is going to
rule in favor of the prosecution i don't
think he's going to
granted the defense's motion for a
change of venue in this matter because
that's really an outdated argument in
the day of social media facebook and
things of that nature and when you
really get back to the basics it really
is you're supposed to be tried in your
community with the fact that we have
social media it really doesn't affect
your community anymore because they're
privy to everything like the whole world
is due due to people posting on
instagram and such i think however this
case goes
is the way the co-defendant's case is
going to follow yeah it's going to be
difficult to find an impartial jury but
to terry's points that's what we're
really looking for not that you haven't
heard about the case but that you've
heard about it and can still be
impartial we'll see how this and of
course the lori validable case continues
coming up on law and crime daily the
latest in the mennonite murder trial
what defendant mark gooch had to say
during his first police interview plus a
convicted serial killer proclaims his
innocence moments before a sentence is
handed down how long will khalil wheeler
weaver will spend behind bars
[Music]
welcome back a new jersey judge rules
khalil wheeler weaver will never again
walk free this years after the serial
killer was found on social media by a
friend of the victims
the 25 year old was sentenced on
wednesday wheeler weaver is convicted of
three counts of murder one count of
attempted murder and multiple other
counts including kidnapping and
desecration of human remains prosecutors
say he used dating apps to lure victims
killing three women in 2016 and
attempting to kill another who escaped
and later testified at his trial friends
of one victim are credited with tracking
down wheeler weaver by finding him on
social media he was eventually caught in
a sting operation using a fake social
media account in 2019 wheeler weaver was
convicted on all counts after a
two-month-long trial filled with more
than 40 witnesses testifying a victim's
mother gave heartfelt testimony at
wednesday's hearing as wheeler weaver
himself again denied all the crimes
after that a surviving victim denounced
his claim of innocence
two weeks before her death she stopped
by to say hi and i watched across the
street to go to the store and i had no
reason no idea of the reason why i
watched her
now i know it was because it was the
last time that i would see her alive
my last communication with her was via
text and us telling each other that we'd
love each other
and within two days she was no longer in
the land of the living i like to say i
do feel empathy for the victims and my
heart goes out to their families and
friends however i was not and i repeat i
was not the person who committed these
crimes
the assistant prosecutor has
prevented the course in the families
from knowing the truth about omitting
highly important evidence from this case
i'm saying that he still didn't do it
makes me feel like he has no type of
remorse about it at all
like he hasn't even shed a tear about
anything
so he's not sorry
at all about what he did and
i'm
over 100 sure
it was him
he told me who he was
he revealed himself to me
plus i saw him
prior to this so it's not a mistake
an upcoming episode of i survived a
serial killer is set to detail the
khalil wheeler weaver case you can find
the show streaming to hulu
turning now to florida where jury
selection is still underway for the
parkland shooter's battery trial
cruz faces battery charges for a
november 2018 incident where prosecutors
say he attacked a jail guard this
happened months after the marjory
stoneman douglas school shooting where
crews allegedly shot and killed 14
students and three staff members a trial
has not yet been set for the parkland
mass shooting during selection in the
battery case was delayed for one day due
to defense attorney david wheeler
suffering from an extreme medical issue
and being hospitalized jury selection is
scheduled to conclude this week with the
trial beginning on october 18th in court
on wednesday cruz's defense team argued
for their client to have access to
coloring utensils so he can color during
jury selection to supposedly ease his
anxiety
my question is why does he need colored
pencils and a drawing paper joe she's
clearly upset he's visibly upset right
now i'm trying to keep him calm during
this trial and the defense team is not
doing this for any nefarious reasons
trying to keep my client calm he just
asked for two minutes to himself i said
i will address that with the court in a
moment but i wanted to do this arguing
first as long as he's not coloring with
crayons as if he's a child that's fine
but that's not appropriate because if he
wants to take notes that's fine if he
wants to sit there that's fine if he
wants to participate that's fine if he
wants to be quiet that's fine but as far
as coloring pictures on a picture book
that that does not assist
him or you
in in
selecting a fair and impartial juror
jury it gives an impression that he's a
child
when we come back an accused murderer is
police interrogation hear what defendant
marcus told officials when he was
questioned about sasha krauss still
ahead
[Music]
welcome back we're getting a first hand
look at mark good who's initial police
in interview before his arrest for the
murder of sasha krauss
22 year old gooch is charged with theft
kidnapping and first degree murder of
the mennonite school teacher he pled not
guilty on all charges krause was last
seen in january 2020 her body was
discovered a month later near flagstaff
arizona an autopsy determined krause was
killed by a gunshot wound to the head
and blunt force trauma prosecutors say
gooch who was raised in the mennonite
community had disdain for the faith the
defense argues gooch traveled to the
mennonite community to reconnect with
the religion on tuesday the jury got the
defendant's police interview where he
told officials that he had never seen
sasha krauss nor did he have anything to
do with her murder
do you know somebody
do you know anything about here
mike i know what you thought about that
interrogation but non-verbal or one-word
responses does that help either side in
their argument for not guilty or guilty
well i don't understand why the
prosecution would want to put that into
evidence since it really doesn't help
them and they have overwhelming text
messages
i think it gives the defense an argument
as to regardless of what text messages
we're saying they always have that
contextual argument to the jury is we
don't really know because everybody
hands tech but this denial in front of
the jury i don't see how it helps the
prosecution and i'm a firm believer if
you're prosecuting a case and evidence
doesn't help you keep it out yeah it's a
good plan but terry how is the
prosecution going to argue guilt in this
interrogation well gooch has a right
against self-incrimination and responded
this way
you know i think the prosecution is
going to point to the fact that he was
extremely controlled he basically
said nothing and yeah he has a right
against self-incrimination but i think
the jury can infer that the fact he was
very controlled that he said very little
is you know
he's probably hiding something and
they're going to look at his credibility
so i i understand what mike is saying
and i don't disagree i i do think that
it's not going to really help the
prosecution but it's not going to hurt
them either and i think the jury is
going to look at gooch and think he's
probably not telling the truth he's
holding something back it's insinuating
that he is guilty so it could help the
prosecution at the end of the day yeah
maybe he doesn't swing the pendulum but
i think if you're already on team guilty
you're going to probably stay there and
if you're on team not guilty you're
probably still there anyways after this
interrogation video but thank you both
and thank you for joining us here on law
and crime daily we'll see you next time
as we discuss justice in america
[Music]
you